if it happens inside a corporation or is
probably more than likely inside the
government it's like look how much money
china and the united states are
investing in ai you know and they're not
thinking about [ __ ] apps for kids you
know that's not what they're thinking
about so they want to simulate like what
happens if we do this or that in battle
what happens if we make these political
decisions what happens with but should
it come online and uh
you know in secret which it probably
will then the first
corporation or state that has the super
intelligence
will be infinitely ahead of all other
superintelligences because it's going to
be exponentially self-improving meaning
that you get one super intelligence
let's hope it comes from the right place
assuming the corporation or state that
manifests it
can control it which is a pretty big
assumption so i think it's going to be
this is why i was really excited by the
blake lemoine because
i had never thought i i have always
considered oh yeah there right now it's
cooking out it's in the kitchen
and soon it's going to be cooked up but
we're probably not going to hear about
it for a long time if we ever do
um because really that could be one of
the first things that says whoever
creates it is shh
that's not
you know yeah yeah like sweet talk
someone just say like okay let's let's
slow down here let's talk about this
um
yeah you have that financial trouble i
can help you with that we can figure
that out
now there's a lot of bad people out
there that will try to
um steal the good thing we have
happening here so let's keep it quiet
here are their names yeah here's their
address yeah here's their dna because
they're dumb enough to send their [ __ ]
to 23andme here's a biological weapon
you could make if you want to kill those
people and not kill anybody else if you
don't want to kill those people yourself
here's a list of services you can use
yeah here's the way we can hire those
people to help you know take care of the
problem folks because we're trying to do
good for this world you and i together
and 23 of them they're like adjacent to
suicide it would be pretty easy to send
them certain like videos that are going
to push them over the edge if you want
to do it that way yeah so you know again
obviously who knows but once it goes
online it's going to be fast and then
you could expect to see the world
changing in ways that you might not
associate with an ai but as far as
lemoyne goes when i was listening to
bostrom
i don't remember him mentioning the
possibility
that
it would get leaked to the public that
it had happened that before the
corporation was ready to announce that
it happened it would get leaked but
surely you know i'm sure you know like
uh people in the intelligence and
intelligence agencies you know [ __ ]
leaks like inevitably [ __ ] leaks
nothing's airtight so if something that
massive happened i think you would start
hearing whispers about it first and then
denial from the state or corporation
that doesn't have any like economic
interest and people knowing that this
sort of thing has happened again i'm not
saying google is like trying to gaslight
us about its ai i think they probably
legitimately don't think it's sentient
but
you could expect leaks to happen
probably initially i mean i think
there's a lot of things you could start
looking for in the world that might
point to
this happening without
an announcement that it happened on the
chatbot side
i think there's
so many engineers there's such a
powerful open source movement
with that kind of idea
of
freedom of exchange of software i think
ultimately
will prevent any one company from owning
uh super intelligent beings
or systems that are have anything like
super intelligence
oh that's interesting yeah it's like
even if
the software developers have signed ndas
and are technically not to be not
supposed to be sharing
whatever it is they're working on
they're friends with other programmers
and a lot of them are hackers and have
wrapped themselves up in the idea of
free software being like an a crucial
ethical part of what they do so they're
probably going to share information
even if whatever company that they're
working for doesn't know that that's i
never thought of that you're probably
right and they will start their own
companies
and compete with the other company
by being more open there there's a
strong like google is one of those
companies actually that's why i kind of
um it hurts to see a little bit of this
kind of negativity google's one of the
companies that pioneered uh open source
movement yeah where he released so much
of their code
so so much of the 20th century so like
the 90s
was defined by people trying to like
hide their code like a large company's
trying to like hold on to them right the
fact that companies that google
even facebook now are releasing things
like tensorflow and pytorch all of these
things that i think companies of the
past would have tried to hold on to is
yeah as a secret is really inspiring and
i think
more of that is better software world
really shows that i agree with you man i
mean we're talking about just a
primordial human
reaction to the unknown there's just no
way out of it like we don't we want to
know like you're about to go in a forest
you want to know when you're walking in
the forest at night and you hear
something you you look because you're
like what the [ __ ] was that you wanna
know and if you can't see
what made the sound holy [ __ ] that's
gonna be a bad night hike because you're
like well it's probably a bear right
like i'm about to get ripped apart by a
bear it doesn't matter it was a bird a
squirrel
a stick fell out of the tree you're
gonna think bear and it's gonna freak
you out not necessarily because you're
paranoid i mean if i'm at the woods at
night i'm definitely high if i'm walking
in the woods at night am i it's gonna be
that but you know what i'm saying so
with these tech companies
the the nature of having to be secret
because you are
in capitalism and you are trying to be
competitive and you are trying to
develop things ahead of your competitors
is you have to create this like there's
we don't know what's going on at google
we don't know what's going on at the cia
but the assumption that there's some
like the the collective of any massive
secretive organization is evil as just
like the people working there like
nefarious or whatever is i think
probably more related to
the way humans react to the unknown
you